la police française n'est pas la police
américaine c'est ce qu'a précisé hier
christophe castaner alors sont elles
vraiment différente c'est de police quid
de leurs méthodes d'interpellation les
mêmes questions de déontologie ce post
elle en france et outre atlantique c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
prêt pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec alexandre langlois
secrétaire général du syndicat vigie
police bonsoir alexandre et envoie merci
d'être avec nous à ses côtés rust
président de l'association banlieues
actives bonsoir à vous en remercie
également d'être en direct une réaction
pour commencer sur cette déclaration du
ministre de l'intérieur la france ce
n'est pas l'amérique
il a raison alexandre langlois oui la
raison la france ce n'est pas l'amérique
là bas en france dans une police
nationale la bassée plus des polices
municipales ou d'état la barre les
personnes face à la police peuvent être
armés tout parce qu'un port d'armes
autorisée en france n'est pas le cas des
gens qui nous avons en face de nous donc
effectivement et ça n'a rien à voir les
règles d'usagé des armes ne sont pas les
mêmes le contexte la population donc ces
deux mondes différents et on peut
trouver quelques similitudes rost
d'accord avec ce diagnostic bon ça qui
est pour le coup factuel mais c'est vrai
que on tente aujourd'hui effectivement
cet amalgame d'aider ce qui se passe
outre atlantique et en france
est ce que vous êtes en accord avec ça
mais il faut distinguer le fait de
pointer du doigt les bavures policières
et le fait qu'il y ait un système qui
soit pratique ça depuis très longtemps
aux états unis il ya mille personnes qui
meurent tous les ans milne loire qui
sont tués tous les ans par la police
dont en france
évidemment on n'est pas assez niveau à
la has à ce niveau là mais il y à des
bavures et lorsqu'on parle de
similitudes c'est plus là dessus que le
que le système en tant que tel est-ce
qu'on a tout de même alexandre lavoie
les mêmes techniques en france qui mène
aux mêmes scènes d'interpellations
pensons évidemment à la faire choux via
un plaquage ventrale c'était en janvier
dernier qui a amené à son décès notre
second d'ailleurs tout à l'heure son
père à 21h est-ce que tout de même c'est
comparable pour le coup à chaque pays a
ses méthodes par contre ce qui est
comparable c'est qu'il ya des résultats
catastrophiques de chaque côté de
l'atlantique
donc chacun avec ses méthodes qui
peuvent être différentes et donc dans la
sphère show via effectivement il y avait
des méthodes d'interpellation en
appuyant certain cachet thoracique qui
ont mené au décès de monsieur souvient
qu'ils sont catastrophiques ça ne
devrait pas exister dans un pays comme
la france
surtout je rappelle pour un contrôle
routier sert qu'à pas mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui avait pas un braquage
on fait aussi à savoir de quoi on parle
c'est aussi le problème de l'egypte qui
n'a aucun rôle pédagogique qui dit il ya
tant de personnes tuées par la police
chaque année voilà mais sans
différencier par exemple le cas de
monsieur chouf via de le cas d'un
terroriste qui a été abattu donc ça
c'est dramatique
donc ne mélangeons pas tout les cas
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'intérieur
veut réformer la formation et les
méthodes d'interpellation c'est tant
mieux
mais est ce qu'on va pouvoir croire
quelqu'un qui ment depuis le début de
son mandat mme et en attend des actes
forts la seule chose qu'on a pu voir de
forts aujourd'hui c'est que bah quand il
y aura des placements evry c'est bien le
premier ministre qui est venu dans la
nuit monsieur castanheira derrière pour
pas qu'ils disent encore des bêtises
voilà donc c'est peut-être un premier
sigle on espère que maintenant la suite
va continuer pour qu'il y ait des
avancées concrètes à la fois pour les
policiers la population et qu'on puisse
regagner un climat de confiance qui est
très compliqué à l'heure actuelle l
excellent loi avant de faire évidemment
réagir rostand rapidement parce que
c'est important dit hey man depuis le
début il raconte des bêtises vous vous
pensez à quoi précisément j'ai jo n'y a
pas de violences policières il n'y a pas
de mutilés il n'y a pas dans un état de
droit
n'est pas possible ne connaît pas de
policiers qu'on fait des violences alors
que ces policiers sont protégés par
l'institution policière
on a bien vu qui a aucune des poursuites
qui sont arrivés et c'est par exemple
pour le cas de cédric du pompier à lyon
c'est olivier béziade c'était le monde
le journal le monde qui a fait l'enquète
plus rapidement que l'igpn est le choix
du ministère ça a été de promouvoir le
préfet de police l'allemand qui étaient
là bas et qui a couvert ces agissements
préfet de police de paris
donc voilà ma deuxième chose d'également
sur leur pastis mme dans la police parce
qu'en fait le racisme on parle du
racisme de la police il ya des racines
dans la police et des collègues en sont
victimes
je rappellerai que ce n'est pas un
problème le nouveau en 2012 2010 il ya
deux collègues entier qui s'est suicidé
la course d'austérité par son
commandant de compagnie la sanction
administrative du commandant a fait
c'est pas bien faut pas recommencer
voilà et la chose encore plus récente
début de l'année notre collègue noah
manoir qui a dénoncé des agissements
racistes à son encontre et à l'encontre
de d'autres collègues
eh ben le choix du ministre de
l'intérieur ça n'a pas été de régler et
de poursuivre les auteurs de ces actes a
été de poursuivre notre délégué parce
qu'il avait dénoncé sur la place
publique pour manque de loyauté envers
la police donc tant qu'on est dans cette
chape de plomb ça n'avancera pas en fait
cirque les lanceurs dallaire dans la
police sont sanctionnés à l'heure
actuelle donc effectivement monsieur
castaner pour le moment n'a pas fait
d'excusés à notre délégué n'a pas
poursuivi des personnes mises en cause
deuxième et dernier point aussi c'est
sur la terre du roi alors je collecte a
eu des chances doit zappa rouen avec des
propos très racistes etc
le ministre de l'intérieur de délégués
dans un manoir donc qui a été sanctionné
avait dit ils seront toujours en poste
dans des années à venir
et là ils vont enfin passer en conseil
de discipline au bout de six mois sans
avoir été suspendu et en ayant assuré la
sécurité de madame belloubet quand les
s'est déplacé au tj de haut rang il ya
quelques jours
or qu'est-ce que vous inspirent les
propos d'alexandre langlois qui n'est
pas ton effectivement avec le ministre
de l'intérieur vous il vous a plutôt
satisfait hier lors de sa conférence de
presse avec ces énoncés et la prise en
compte
effectivement d'un problème de racisme
chez certains policiers
c'était plutôt satisfaisant écoutez moi
je franchement si on avait eu des
personnes comme monsieur langlois
il ya quelques années de ça on aurait
évité certainement beaucoup de mutiler
et beau
de bavures policières et certainement
aussi des morts donc je tiens à le
remercier de parler aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est à une période très
historique
vraiment j'ai comme des millions de
français
au lendemain des attentats de charlie
hebdo et ceux qui ont suivi comme
renault j'ai embrassé un flic et on
était heureux de notre police ont été on
était fier on l'a défendu on a on à
porter haut ses couleurs sur toutes ces
périodes là et puis quelques temps après
les le quotidien a repris le dessus et
les comportements déviants de certains
encore une fois il s'agit pas et moi je
les ai toujours dit c'est un combat que
je mène depuis très longtemps et ce qui
est important
si j'ai toujours dit que la police
française est à l'image de la france de
même société
c'est à dire qu'il y a des gens bien
vous avez aussi une petite frange qui
des brebis galeuses
au même titre que dans nos quartiers
vous avez aussi qu'une petite frange qui
fout le bordel et d'où il faut faire le
ménage et ses impératifs
le discours du ministre hier on dit les
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui y
croient
moi je suis devenu un peu comme saint
thomas je ne vois je ne crois que ce que
je vois
donc attendons de voir réellement et
concrètement ce qui va être fait avant
de crier victoire
tous ces déplacements la déplacements
qui sont faits actuellement tous et
toute cette agitation
elle vise à quoi à calmer les choses
pour éviter que les banlieues ne
s'embrase
mais il savons plus que ce n'est pas il
n'y a pas que les banlieues terrisse de
s'embraser
parce que vous avez les effets du co
vide qui vont arriver dont très peu de
ton avec cette france qui va être
licencié massivement avec ceux qui vont
fermer leur petit business ainsi de
suite et tout ça est en train de
s'agréger sur une colère contre un
gouvernement qui jusqu'à présent étaient
dans le mépris dans le déni et de tout
ce qui se passait et des réalités que
certains d'entre nous qui sommes sur le
terrain tous les jours et ce en essayant
de porter en étant né compte du silence
de la masse silencieuse qui ne s'exprime
pas elle qu'on n'entend pas alors
messieurs je voulais vous faire réagir
sur cette déclaration
d'olivier marchal vous savez cet ancien
flic un passé on le sait dans le monde
du cinéma le réalisateur de 36 quai des
enfers il était l'invité d'une chaîne de
télé française hier et il a piqué un
coup de colère écouter quand on choisit
le métier de flic
on le choisit pour servir et protéger
j'ai des flics pendant 12 ans je n'ai
pas fait flics pour casser de l'arabe et
du noir tous les flics qui rentre dans
la police veulent servir et protéger les
sans emploi va servir et protéger allez
monsieur marshall qui dit aussi les
flics sont devenus un petit peu les
boucs émissaires ça vous inspire quoi
justement cette remarque d'olivier
marchal de défendre quand même
effectivement ses anciens collègues
ça m'inspire de choses première c'est
que malheureusement il y à des policiers
qui rentre avec de mauvaises intentions
dans la police nationale
et malheureusement cette minorité n'est
pas filtrée au niveau du concours
d'entrée et ce qui se passe depuis que
monsieur macro et président de la
république
le concours il la première année il ya
eu 300 personnes qui n'ont pas pu être
pris longtemps la police pas 300 postes
qui n'ont pas été pourvus parce que il
n'y avait pas des gens qui avaient le
niveau pour passer le concours on est
descendu à 8 de moyenne l'année suivante
on s'est dit on va augmenter les
salaires prendre des mesures salariales
pour attirer des personnes qui ont le
niveau pour passer le concours
la mesure qui a été prise et est en
train de baisser le niveau du concours
de toujours prendre à 8 de moyenne et
mais malgré cela voilà il y avait 200
postes non pourvus à tel point que le
directeur de la formation
monsieur lutz on est alarmé dans le
journal le monde en disant qu'il ne
pourrait rien faire des personnes qu'on
lui envoie la deuxième chose aussi c'est
là je raconte est aussi un encadrement
et une difficulté c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de policiers qui arrive en
ile-de-france dans des cités difficiles
et qu'ils ne sont pas formés à arriver
dans ces quartiers là c'est
malheureusement pour la police mais dans
le cas de beaucoup de postes dans la
fonction publique j'ai des amis dans
l'éducation nationale qui me racontent
la même chose est en fait ya des choses
qui s'appelle avec l'expérience de la
vie on ne réagit pas de la même façon à
20 ans 30 ans 40 ans et avec le recul et
ben on arrive par exemple tout feu tout
flamme à 20 ans on se dit ouah je vais
faire comme à bfmtv je vais tout casser
je vais révolutionner jeu jouent aux cow
boy
la réalité c'est pas ça il y avait des
anciens qui avaient
du plomb dans l aile qui disaient non on
va discuter le but du jeu c'est
d'apaiser les choses de faire de la
prévention
on fait de la répression que quand c'est
nécessaire et à l'heure actuelle ce
n'est pas le cas donc olivier marchal
essaye de défendre la boutique c'est
très bien malheureusement la police a
évolué et la police qui l'a connu
n'évolue pas forcément dans le temps
enfin la police actuel n'est pas
forcément celle qu'il a connue
malheureusement alors par contre il a
raison sur une chose c'est une minorité
de policiers nous on en veut énormément
à notre hiérarchie qui ne fait pas le
ménage dans nos rangs et qui poursuit
les gens voient la race que le mot de la
fin sera ces remarques
écoutez moi je franchement je pense que
vraiment à tout point de vue on est dans
une période historique en tombant ce
genre de discours mais vous même les
journalistes de couronnes avec vous pas
de donner la parole à ces gens là on
aurait évité beaucoup de drames
j'insiste dessus donc aujourd'hui la
jeune attaquant peut volontairement mais
voilà mais c'est vrai que nous pendant
très longtemps on a essayé d'organiser
des débats entre la police les jeunes au
moment de la suppression de la police de
proximité
je fais partie de ceux qu'on lançait une
pétition pour rétablir une autre vision
de la police que celle qui est là juste
pour faire de la répression
et aujourd'hui on a cette chance malgré
tout malgré les drames parfois il faut
ça pour peut-être améliorer les choses
pouvons-nous nous sommes en train de
mettre en place un gros événement très
prochainement pour essayer de renouer le
lien de recréer du dialogue et voir
comment on peut sortir des belles choses
de ce qui est en train de se passer à
travers ces drames
merci on terminera sur cette note
positive merci à tous les deux d'avoir
été en direct avec nous